this is a second thought video made
possible by Squarespace make your next
move with a beautiful website from
Squarespace it seems like there's always
some new mission announcement or
groundbreaking discovery and space
exploration but we never seem to hear
anything more about it why is that
usually it's because planning for and
executing missions in outer space takes
a huge amount of preparation it's not
uncommon to hear about a proposed
mission 5 10 even 20 years in advance
that being said we do have some
fascinating and exciting space missions
lined up over the next few years and
decades let's take a look at what's next
for space exploration starting with the
nearest upcoming event in March of 2018
NASA will launch their transiting
exoplanet survey satellite or Tess
Tess's job will be to scan the night sky
for nearby bright stars that host rocky
exoplanets cataloging the best bets for
near future studies and far future
potential manned missions test is
expected to catalogue over 3,000
exoplanets during its two-year mission
including approximately 500 earth sized
and super-earth planets in May of 2018
NASA will launch the new insight Mars
Lander with touchdown expected in late
November insight will study the interior
of Mars to understand more about the
evolutionary formation of rocky planets
including earth in August NASA's
osiris-rex spacecraft will arrive at the
asteroid Bennu and collect samples for
return to earth in September of 2023
while this may not sound terribly
exciting the osiris-rex mission actually
has the potential to answer some of our
biggest questions about the origin of
life asteroids are considered the
original stuff of the solar system
leftover pieces from the cataclysmic
nebula collapse in which the solar
system was formed over four-and-a-half
billion years ago a sample from Ben who
could prove or disprove the theory that
the surface of the earth was scorched
into oblivion and then later receded
with life from asteroid impacts in
addition to potentially answering this
burning question the osiris-rex mission
has another objective Venu is a very
large asteroid measuring over 500 meters
in diameter taller than the Empire State
Building which makes it a great
candidate for a safe probe landing but
it's also on a collision course with
earth sometime in the 22nd century Benno
is expected to crash into our planet
causing untold devastation the
osiris-rex team hopes to study the
it's physical and chemical properties
which will be critical in forming an
impact mitigation mission in the spring
of 2019 the long-awaited and
state-of-the-art James Webb Space
Telescope will finally launch Webb is
intended to be the premier Space
Telescope of the next decade with
greatly improved capabilities over its
predecessor Hubble it's so powerful that
it will be able to see all the way back
to around thirteen point five billion
years ago when the first stars and
galaxies began to form out of the
darkness of the early universe in
addition to being a veritable time
machine Webb's unprecedented infrared
sensitivity will allow astronomers to
compare the faintest earliest galaxies
to the grand spirals and ellipticals of
today helping us to understand how
galaxies form over billions of years the
Space Telescope will be able to see
right through the giant clouds of dust
that are opaque to current observatories
like Hubble where stars and planetary
systems are being born
finally Webb will be able to tell us
more about the atmospheres of distant
exoplanets and maybe even find the
building blocks of life elsewhere in the
universe the James Webb Space Telescope
will give astronomers powerful new tools
to study some of the most interesting
questions about the origins of the
universe itself
and who knows what other amazing
discoveries it will make possible
starting in 2020 and going into 2021
Mars is going to get quite a handful of
new robotic visitors in addition to
NASA's Mars 2020 Rover which will study
the red planet's habitability and
explore for signs of past life the
European Space Agency is launching their
own Rover called ExoMars the United Arab
Emirates will attempt to launch their
first Mars orbiter and China plans to
launch their own Rover both nasa's mars
2020 and the esa ExoMars intend not only
to search for past or present microbial
life on the red planet but also to
perform a thorough analysis of mars as
climate geology and overall habitability
to prepare for upcoming manned missions
in 2022 we'll get to witness the launch
of the highly anticipated Jupiter icy
moons Explorer spacecraft also known as
juice juice will study the Jovian moons
Ganymede Callisto and Europa some of the
most likely places to find life beyond
Earth
each of these moons has an incredible
amount of ice covering potentially huge
bodies of liquid water and if there's
anything we understand about water here
on earth it's that wherever there is
water there is life juice is scheduled
to enter an orbit around Jupiter in 2030
and will spend at least three years
making detailed observations of these
promising
SeaWorld's also scheduled for 2022 is
the first unmanned mission to Mars by
SpaceX while Elon Musk admits this is a
lofty goal he believes it is possible
the objectives of this first cargo
mission are to confirm water resources
identify potential hazards and establish
initial power mining and life-support
infrastructure for the Mars mission
everyone has been waiting for which
brings us to 2024 the scheduled year for
landing the first humans on Mars
this second SpaceX mission loaded with
both cargo and crew aims to build a
propellant Depot on Mars to prepare for
future manned flights musk intends for
these initial ships and their cargo to
serve as the beginnings of our first
Mars base from which we can expand and
eventually create a thriving
self-sustaining City if we can achieve
this challenging goal Humanity will
officially become a multiplanetary
species greatly lessening the risk of a
complete extinction event musk also
speculates that if all goes according to
plan we could have a Martian colony of a
million people within 40 to a hundred
years if SpaceX doesn't manage to land
humans on Mars we won't be out of
options just yet nASA has been prepping
to send humans to Mars for some time
after another decade or so of intensive
testing and planning they'll attempt a
manned mission to the Red Planet
sometime in the early to mid 2030s on
their Mars mission webpage NASA shares
their optimism for the future saying
Mars is the next tangible frontier for
human exploration and it's an achievable
goal there are challenges to pioneering
Mars but we know they're solvable we are
well on our way to getting there landing
there and living there this video really
doesn't even scratch the surface of the
whole list of planned missions within
the next 50 years but you can already
tell just how exciting the next few
decades will be will we find life on
Europa hidden clues to the origins of
the entire universe thanks to the James
Webb telescope will our grandchildren
and great-grandchildren call Mars their
home we'll just have to wait and see in
the meantime why not make your own
website to catalog your predictions for
the future of space exploration with
Squarespace it's not rocket science to
create your own professional website
Squarespace has tons of easy to edit
templates created by world-class
designers to get your shiny new website
up and running in a matter of hours
these days it's so important to have a
web presence to show off your work sell
merchandise or just to be noticed and
thanks to Squarespace it's a whole lot
easier than you might
Specht so if you want to start a blog
sell a product or make a cool website
tracking humanity's progress in space I
can't recommend Squarespace highly
enough to check out Squarespace and
support second thought visit Squarespace
calm / second thought today if you
enjoyed this video consider subscribing
to support the channel and keep up to
date on the latest content and click
that little bell to be notified every
time I release a new video you can watch
the rest of my space related content by
clicking here or if you're really bored
you can binge watch all my content by
clicking here thanks for watching and
I'll see you next week